[Applause]
all right kg
you got the floor man anything you want
to say to these people
no i just want to say thank you again
wick thank ownership
i want to thank danny ainge for the
vision
i want to thank doc rivers for coaching
us hard and
getting us to a point where we was
invincible
i want to thank all the guys man for
showing up thank y'all for coming here
today man meant a lot man
it's all the celtics that's playing here
man thank y'all for staying i appreciate
it jt
all y'all man i root for y'all man good
luck in the playoffs keep kicking some
ass keep playing together you know what
i'm saying
last not least man i want to thank all
y'all man
it's been real man i would have never
thought y'all love me like this
i love you boston i love you northeast
i love y'all man
[Applause]
beaten
[Applause]
this is the moment
we've all been waiting for
a culmination of a legendary career and
at this time we welcome kevin and his
family
over to the banner as they raise it to
its rightful place up in the rafters
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how about one final applause
for number five kevin thank you god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you once again to all the fans and
distinguished guests